Ang classical optimization ay isang mahalagang hakbang sa classical-quantum algorithms
tulad ng variational quantum eigensolver o quantum machine learning.
Pero madalas na mahirap i-minimize
ang mga kumplikadong function sa mataas na dimensyonal na parameter spaces.
Ako si Victoria Lipinska at sa video na ito, titingnan natin
ang mga classical optimization routines para sa classical-quantum algorithms.
Hindi madali ang mga optimization problems.
Habang dumadami ang mga parameter, dumadami rin ang posibleng
kombinasyon ng mga value, at exponential ang paglaki nito.
Sa chess, halimbawa, mayroon itong 64 na puwesto
at 16 piraso ang bawat manlalaro. Pagkatapos ng isang galaw ng bawat manlalaro,
may 400 na iba't ibang posisyon. Pagkatapos ng dalawang galaw, 72,084 na posisyon,
mga 9 milyon pagkatapos ng tatlo at mga
280 bilyon pagkatapos ng apat na galaw.
Kung aabot lang tayo sa 40 galaw, ang bilang ng posibleng posisyon
ay tinatayang sampung nasa kapangyarihan ng 120.
Para maglaro ng perpektong laro, kailangan mong tuklasin ang lahat ng posibleng
posisyon, at dahil sa napakalaking bilang na ito, hindi praktikal
ang isa-isahin ang bawat posisyon.
Maaari itong malutas sa pamamagitan ng paghati ng problema sa dalawang mas maliit na sub-problems.
Una, kailangan nating tukuyin kung aling mga setup ng chessboard
ang malamang na lalabas sa mga susunod na hakbang ng ating laro.
Ito ang ating tatawagin na subspace of interest.
At pangalawa, batay sa subspace na iyon, kailangan nating alamin kung ano ang pinakamabuting galaw.
Ito ang ating tatawagin na pinakamabuting galaw.
Sa analohiyang ito, ang unang paghahanap sa subspace of interest
ay katumbas ng ating classical optimization algorithm.
Kapag natukoy na ang subspace of interest,
isang quantum algorithm ang karaniwang responsable sa paghanap ng pinakamabuting galaw,
batay sa subspace na iyon.
Magsimula tayo sa pagtingin sa isang parameter lang,
theta, na nagpaparameter ng cost function na gusto nating i-optimize.
Kung ipo-plot natin ang function, sabihin nating ganito ang hitsura nito,
sa X-axis ay makikita ang mga value ng parameter theta
at sa Y-axis naman ay ang cost function.
Tandaan na ang cost function ay maaaring isang tunay na financial cost
na gusto nating i-minimize, o tulad ng madalas na nangyayari sa variational quantum
eigensolver, maaari itong isang energy na ina-minimize ng kalikasan.
Ang ating layunin ay hanapin ang theta
na tumutugma sa pinakamababang cost.
Nagsisimula tayo sa isang paunang value ng theta at sa bawat hakbang ng optimization
naghahanap tayo ng bagong theta na nagpapababa ng cost.
Mukhang madali nating malaman kung aling direksyon ang susundan sa graph kung makikita natin ito.
Pero ang kahirapan sa optimization ay hindi talaga natin ito makikita.
Nalalaman lang natin ang cost — isang maliit na piraso ng buong larawan —
kapag sine-evaluate natin ang function sa napiling theta.
Ganito ang pangkalahatang paraan ng optimization.
Ang optimizer ay nagsa-sample ng mga parameter theta at kinakalkula ang cost.
Tulad ng maiisip mo, hindi masyadong epektibo ang random na pagpili ng theta para mabuo
ang buong topology ng function.
Sa halip, ang ginagawa ng mga matalinong optimizer ay ang paghanap
ng gradient ng function sa bawat hakbang.
Sa ganitong paraan, alam ng optimizer kung aling direksyon sa plot
ang susundan para mahanap ang pinakamababang cost.
Kapag zero na ang gradient, tinatapusin ang algorithm
at nahanap na ang minimum.
Ang minimum na ito ay maaaring hindi ang global minimum.
Maaari itong isang local minimum,
ibig sabihin ito ang pinakamababang value ng cost function sa kalapit na lugar
ngunit hindi sa buong hanay ng theta.
Sa kaso ng isang parameter, posible iyon.
Pero habang dumadami ang ating mga parameter,
nagiging mas kumplikado ang function.
Sa kaso na ng dalawang parameter, mayroon na tayong isang surface,
at sa apat na parameter, hindi na natin ito kayang iguhit.
Tulad ng sa halimbawa ng chess, ang pagre-reproduce ng lahat ng posibilidad
ay mabilis na nagiging hindi na kaya.
Nakikita natin na mahirap i-minimize
ang mga kumplikadong function sa mataas na dimensyonal na parameter spaces.
Gayunpaman, para makakuha ng makatwirang resulta, gusto nating maging mabilis
at tumpak ang mga classical optimization routines.
Kailangan din nilang maging matibay laban sa ingay,
na magkakaroon ng malaking epekto sa mga near-term quantum computers.
Ang mga classical optimization algorithm ay maaaring hatiin
sa dalawang uri — direct search at gradient based methods.
Ang gradient based methods ay nangangailangan ng impormasyon tungkol sa gradient
ng function sa panahon ng optimization process.
Maaari itong kalkulahin nang analytical
o matantiya sa pamamagitan ng finite difference calculation.
Ang direct search methods ay hindi gumagamit ng gradient information
at gumagamit ng ibang mga estratehiya para i-minimize ang cost function.
Ilan sa mga pinakakaraniwang ginagamit na optimization algorithms
sa larangan ng quantum computing ay ang mga sumusunod na optimizer.
Ang COBYLA ay nangangahulugang constrained optimization by linear approximation
at ito ay isang gradient-free optimization algorithm.
Ang SLSQP ay sequential least squares programming,
isang gradient based optimization algorithm.
Gumagamit ito ng stochastic perturbation vector
para sabay na kalkulahin ang approximate gradient ng cost function.
Sa isang walang ingay na kapaligiran, ang mga optimizer tulad ng COBYLA
at SLSQP ay mas mabilis na nag-converge kaysa sa SPSA.
Ang mga classical optimizer ay may sariling mga parameter
na maaari mong itakda para sa mga partikular na kaso, halimbawa, ang step size.
Karaniwang makikita ang mga ito sa dokumentasyon na may kaugnayan
sa partikular na optimizer.
Hinihikayat kita na tingnan ang listahan ng mga sanggunian sa ibaba para sa paghahambing
ng mga pinaka-updated na classical optimizer.
Tuklasin natin ang isa pang penomenong may kaugnayan
sa classical optimization ng mga parameterized quantum circuits.
Tulad ng nakita natin kanina, ang nawawalang gradient ng cost function ay maaaring magpahiwatig
na ang optimizer ay napadpad sa isang patag na lugar na walang kawili-wiling katangian — ang tinatawag na
"barren plateau."
Ang barren plateau ay maaaring bunga ng maraming salik.
Ang gradient ng cost function na katumbas ng isang quantum circuit
na may random na na-initialize na mga parameter
ay exponential na bumababa sa zero habang dumadami ang mga qubit.
Ito ay dahil ang quantum space na tinutuklas ng optimizer
ay nagiging exponentially malaki habang dumadami ang mga qubit.
Ang mga paraan para harapin ang problemang ito ay kinabibilangan ng pagbabawas ng bilang ng mga parameter
at samakatuwid ang dimensyon ng pinagbabatayan na space.
Isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa pinagmulan ng barren plateau issue
ay ang problem-agnostic na katangian ng parameterized circuit
na kinakaharap ng exponentially malaking parameter space.
Ang pagdisenyo ng circuit sa paraang angkop sa isinasaalang-alang
na problema ay maaaring maging magandang solusyon.
Bukod sa exponential na parameter space na nagdudulot ng barren plateaus,
ang iba pang mga pisikong penomeno ay maaari ring magdulot nito:
ang ingay at decoherence na nangyayari sa mga quantum computing experiments,
ang kabuuang expressibility ng parameterized circuit,
o ang nonlocality at antas ng entanglement ng cost function na ginagawang modelo.
Nananatiling aktibong lugar ng pananaliksik ang pagtugon sa mga hamong ito.
Ngayong nareview na natin ang mga pangunahing bahagi ng VQE,
ibubuod natin ang algorithm sa susunod na video.